that is what is so interesting to me
about the placebo effect is that it is a
real thing yet your mind has this
capability of healing itself in this
very very powerful way but we don't
exactly know how to turn it on or off
right and it can do the opposite too
there's a phenomenon called voodoo death
where in societies where there
witchdoctor shamans a malevolent witch
doctor can curse a person and the person
goes home lies in bed stops eating and
over days or weeks dies whoa
so what more could you ask of in the way
of a in my body effect he put a curse on
what was the basketball team they were
talking [ __ ] about him he put a curse on
them and they couldn't win a goddamn
game I had a few times
yeah he's put a curse on a few different
- he's like a real how would you say
spiritual very positive mostly like real
love oriented guy but occasionally he'll
put a hex on a dude uh-huh and when he
puts a hex on you got a real problem on
your heart apparently it's been very
effective and people freak out when Lil
B hex ISM little B puts that hex on you
like damn it and then he releases the
hex haha he's lifted them he lifts the
huh and when he lifts them everything
goes back to normal
alright this is weird man this is like a
weird sock because everyone's aware when
Lil B puts a curse on you
uh-huh and when he does people are
called no I can't believe this okay like
the idea of curses like the the you know
a voodoo curse or a gypsy curse on you
that is a well that's the negative cited
and as a name it's called the nocebo
effect obnoxious rather than pleasing
yes yeah that is that's a documented
thing as well right the people that can
believe that something is wrong with
them and then they start mind yeah
[ __ ] themselves into this terrible
state yeah and then they start screwing
things up yeah yeah here it is Kevin
Durant says I tried to listen a little B
my mind wouldn't let me do it can't
believe this guy's relevant I was like
okay [ __ ] Kevin Durant will never win
the title after he said Lil B is a wack
rapper the bass gods curse hashtag the
bass God's curse on Durant
and then he always signs his tweets Lil
B
but it works it works Kevin Durant is
sitting home right now thinking of the
millions a little bit mr. Coston what
yeah is one now yeah one now but the
kids could have bought a house with all
that money loss back those years it will
be [ __ ] over in the corner but that I
mean I think the opposite is true too so
someone could put blessings on you like
there was a fighter that we had in here
the other day Deontay Wilder he's the
WBC heavyweight champion the world and
he said that from the time he was a
little boy his grandmother had him
convinced that he was like an anointed
one that he was special and that she
would always say that to his parents
like you know don't you hit him like
this one's special
you know he's gonna raise everybody up
and then he turned out to be like one of
the great heavyweight champions ever in
terms of like his record he's 40 you
know with 39 knockouts and he's a
phenomenally successful fighter and in
his mind he believes that he has some
like magic property or there's something
to him he's a ridiculous knockout artist
to me obviously there's a lot of
physiological aspects to that he's a big
long tall guy with crazy knockout power
you can't fake power you either have it
or you don't but he's got it and he's
got this weird confidence too and you
gotta wonder how much of them actually
is operating under this idea that his
grandmother was right about him having
some magical properties and so he goes
through life is his vision yeah powerful
yeah how you trick people into thinking
that way a whole nation full Deonte wow
there's